bonjour et bienvenue dans fit l'écho ce
magazine sera consacrée aux difficultés
du secteur du bâtiment un secteur qui
concerne 10% de l'activité économique
des yvelines d'après la fédération
française du bâtiment
le climat morose de 2012 devrait
persister pour l'année à venir
elle prévoit un recul en volume de 3 8%
et près de 1500 emplois détruits dans le
département une situation difficile pour
les salariés mais aussi pour les jeunes
recrues
c'est ce que nous découvrirons au centre
de formation des métiers du bâtiment
mais tout d'abord pour faire un point
sur la situation nous retrouvons pierre
cojan pierre cojan bonjour bonjour vous
êtes vice président de la fédération
française du bâtiment des yvelines mais
également vous êtes à la tête d'une
entreprise de maçonnerie depuis 1976 on
peut dire que vous connaissez bien le
milieu
ces difficultés est ce que c'est quelque
chose de nouveau ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on a déjà connu dans le
milieu
non moi depuis que j'ai créé mon
entreprise il ya des difficultés mais
comment est ce jour là vous parliez de
d'une diminution de trois et demi
pour cent je pense qu'on va aller
beaucoup plus sur 2013 ça devient
inquiétant
on a entre autres la perte d'emploi est
alors vous disiez on est indigne de son
entreprise
1500 salariés c'est énorme donc cette
baisse d'activité concrètement elle se
voit comment dans votre société
la baisse d'activité
l'epu un peu la ressentir avant la vraie
crise donc moi j'ai réduit mon chiffre
d'affaires parce que les affaires
étaient difficiles les prix trop bas
donc on peut pas se mettre en porte à
faux
et puis on a une trésorerie est conservé
dans le magazine m'a permis de m'adapter
et s'adresser une reprise familiale
personnelle est avec moi depuis
longtemps donc je tiens à le conserver
et puis on attend que ça reprenne bon
maintenant c'est un peu difficile
vous avez diminué de beaucoup vous
commande que ce soit en entreprise
oui oui on a réduit lors on a réduit
l'activité et on s'est concentré sur des
petits chantiers ce qu'il représente
beaucoup plus de travail mais à plus
forte rentabilité mais épuisant et on
aurait envie d'avoir de gros chantiers
avoir donné espoir un peu à tous nos
collaborateurs
justement le dernier rapport de
l'observatoire régional de l'artisanat
en bâtiment en ile de france indique
qu'une entreprise sur deux un carnet de
commandes de moins d'un mois
vous qui avez une ancienneté assez
importante ce que vous pensez que ça
peut vous aider
c'est ce que c'est les petites
entreprises qui sont les premières
touchées
oui ben nous nous les anciens on a une
expérience qui fait que n'a pu mieux
appréhender la difficulté mais les
jeunes entreprises sont d'abord en
difficulté parce qu'ils ont moins
trésorerie mon ancienneté et puis l'ont
pas de motivation il y en a peu de
motiver au vu de ce qui se passe les
cous en fait de cette baisse de régime
se réduit seulement à la crise
économique aux difficultés des ménages
ou est ce que il ya d'autres raisons les
causes c'est qu'on a actuellement une
main-d'oeuvre et loyal européenne qui
vient des taux trop trop trop faible non
salaires chargés on arrive à 3 fois le
prix de ce que propose l'union
européenne on a aussi les entrepreneurs
c'est une petite structure qui fait que
nos pattes tva on pas de charge donc
pour nous c'est plus en plus difficile
notre puce pour les petits entrepreneurs
les petits
l'artisan s'installe donc vous évoquez
la concurrence des entreprises
étrangères de l'union européenne
les auto entrepreneurs est-ce qu'on peut
prendre aussi en compte par exemple la
hausse de la tva on peut être les
durcissements du prêt à taux zéro oui
belle à la hausse de la tva
on avait 5 % 5 et 10% ça ça fait du bien
tout les petites entreprises
et puis ils leur ont mis 7 % à 7 % on a
passé maintenant c'est 10% à partir de
la prochaine et pourquoi pas plus donc
là les gens ont des motifs de l'anader
c'est un surcoût est au moins au
démotive les gens à investir
vous avez lancé en fait une journée
mobilisation le 31 janvier vous avez
notamment envoyer des cartes postales au
préfet alors est-ce que vous pensez que
l'état peut faire quelque chose par
exemple pour votre entreprise
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez quel
changement je souhaite demain tva reste
à 7 c voir revenir à 5 serait
merveilleux à 7
on s'adaptera mais on n'arrive pas à 10
il ya plus passant dans les charges il
faudrait réduire les charges façon ce
que la concurrence qui travaillent à
trois fois moins cher que nous on puisse
lire approcher et puis moi j'ai une
entreprise que j'ai depuis plus trente
sept ans maintenant je voudrais qu un
jour là de la cds et fois que derrière
les gens qui me suivent qui sont l'air
mois est en vie actuellement ils sont
pas envie il faut il faut leur donner
l'espoir de pérenniser cette entreprise
et ce bâtiment qui est merveilleux
pierre que je remercie mon pause nous
partons maintenant attrape au centre de
formation des métiers du bâtiment pour
rejoindre gilles robion le directeur
bonjour j'ai lu revient chaque année 150
apprentis sorte de votre centre ils sont
diplômés en peinture en maçonnerie en
étanchéité vous ne recevez d'ailleurs
dans votre atelier de maçonnerie alors
avec la morosité du marché actuel est ce
que les jeunes sont assurés de trouver
du travail
alors écoutez je vais vous répondre que
ceux qui sont chez nous font leurs deux
ou trois ans de formation que ça dépend
des formations qui restent jusqu'au bout
qui globalement ont pratiquement tous
leurs diplômes sont là des résultats qui
sont excellents cela oui en général
n'ont pas de problème pour trouver du
travail
c'est plus compliqué finalement en amont
avant parce que nous avons des apprentis
vaut un panty par définition ou un
patron ce patron ça se passe bien les
gardent souvent les garder à formule
pour les garder à près d'un cas pratique
c'est plutôt parce que j'ai quand même
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont des
soucis
nous travaillons dans le bâtiment est
beaucoup de petites entreprises tpe
d'artisans qui sont un peu les premiers
à souffrir de ce problème économique un
celles qui ont des soucis est
actuellement quand tu du manque de
visibilité des soucis financiers de
beaucoup de choses puis quand même à
certains freins certaine réticence et a
recruté ce qui me paraît
évident est donc à prendre des jeunes
même en apprentissage des avantages
économiques que c'est jamais facile on
ne sait si on ne sait pas qu'on va car
dans six mois c'est compliqué donc oui
c'est difficile c'est difficile on a du
mal de placer nos jeunes de trouver pour
tous un patron qui veuille bien les
prendre pour remédier à ce problème
vous êtes adaptée à la situation qu'est
ce qui a été mis en place entre ap on
fait beaucoup de choses d'une part si
hauts ces efforts on a décidé qu'un
jeune s'inscrivait en maçonnerie
je suis un peu au début mais n'y avait
pas de patrons on le prend ou bien il
commença sur la formation
je cherche un patron si vraiment ils
trouvent ça on va l'aider dans la
période des carrières de raison qu'elle
ait du monde et là on va effectivement
faire des choix c'est à dire en fonction
du profil du jeune on va choisir un
petit peu attendu mais choisir un peu
l'entreprise pour proposer j'allais dire
le bon jeune à la bonne entreprise
ça permet de pouvoir classer facilement
des jeunes ensuite de quoi on contacte
régulièrement les chefs d'entreprise on
a des réunions avec eux avec des drh
avec des écouteurs pour parler de ce
qu'ils attendent de notre formation on
peut adapter une partie de notre
formation à ce que désire faisable c'est
à dire comment vous adaptez je veux dire
des entreprises font chaque entreprise
devait pas exactement la même chose aux
métiers du bâtiment
enfin ne serait ce qu en maçonnerie donc
il ya des choses que feront sur le
chantier quand le jeune été entreprises
nous verrons parfaitement ils ne verront
pas entreprises et nous on va développer
cette partie là avec le jeune au cfa on
va essayé d'individualiser au maximum la
formation pour répondre aux besoins
donc ça c'est une solution qui permet de
dire
aux patrons regarder on vous propose des
jeunes et on va travailler avec vous
proposer ce que vous voulez vous bout du
compte pour qu'il soit j'allais dire
presque rentable on apprend qu'il n'est
pas rentable à la fin et surtout qu'il
dit tout vu comme ça vous pourrez
utiliser partout et puis en plus on dit
souvent avec des entreprises qui sont un
peu floués qui se disait ce que les
jeunes de maintenant c'est la grande
forme les jeunes de maintenant c'est pas
comme avant
or du député premier d'un stage d'où ils
sont au cfa nous on les forme prenez-le
en stage pour une semaine qu'un jura
mois et tout ce temps là vous voyez que
ça va
prenons en apprentissage rolland propose
des stages la région nous permet de
travailler comme ça donc c'est une
flexibilité en quelque sorte
au lieu de commencer l'apprentissage dès
le début de la formation il commence par
des petits stages certains bons sur six
c'est un peu compliqué commencé par des
petits stages dans diverses ou dans une
entreprise pour confirmer leur
apprentissage
et puis enfin si malheureusement on
n'arrive vraiment pas à trouver une
entreprise ce jeune là ou si par malheur
l'entreprise a été obligé de fermer ont
été obligés de licencier pour diverses
raisons
jacques grâce à la région on peut parler
de la région ile-de-france les systèmes
qui existent on peut quasiment garder un
jeune homme pendant presqu'un an au cfa
sous statut particulier de stagiaires de
la formation professionnelle continue al
formé lui trouver un patron pour la
deuxième année voire même si c'est en
deuxième année l'amener à l'examen pour
qu'ils réussissent sont souvent assez
particulier il ya pratiquement et l'île
de france qui fait ça il faut aussi une
dernière option c'est finalement de
continuer les études les pousser à
continuer sur un bac pro derrière alors
pour ceux qui le souhaitent
parce que tout le monde ne le seraient
pas des deux jeunes gens qui ne
souhaitent pas forcément pour ceux qui
le peuvent également pour les
entreprises qui souhaitent aussi avoir
des jeunes gens un peu plus fort mais on
leur propose de poursuivre on a des
jeunes qui rentrent en 6 ap on peut leur
proposer le bac couple voire au delà
la poursuite d'études et à des moyens
d'avoir des informations et de se placer
petrus votre contribution
j'ai le rovio merci son prix on s'est
donné un atout supplémentaire
les élèves se forment également à l'éco
construction ça leur permet de surfer
sur la vague écolo illustration en
images
jean-luc guiborat vérifie niveau
aplanies un travail de préparation
minutieuse balle au final poser des
parpaings une technique étonnante car il
s'agit ici de parpaings plus écologique
le mortier ne sert plus qu'à la base les
blocks en boîte et les joints seront
proposés le col finie la truelle pour
remonter trentaine de mètres carrés de
blocs traditionnels
il vous faut à peu près entre 10 et 15
tonnes de sable là pour poser trente
mètres carrés de blocs en maçonnerie
rouler avec un sac et demi de deux cols
de 25 kg j'arrive à poser les trempettes
correctement économie de matériaux de
main d'oeuvre mais aussi meilleure
isolation les joueurs ne mesure que 2
millimètres contre 15 des mortiers avec
la méthode classique un moyen de
rentabiliser l'investissement des blocs
de 10 à 20% plus cher que les parpaings
habituel mais surtout de respecter la
réglementation actuelle plus exigeantes
en terme d'isolation et de répondre aux
besoins des entreprises
c'est quelque chose avec lequel
travaille le plus de plus en plus donc
il faut que nos jeunes soient
opérationnels et
puis se déployer rapidement avec ces
nouveaux matériaux qu'ils soient pas
perdus tout de suite ça c'est quelque
chose d'assez important surtout avec la
conjoncture est une opportunité pour les
72 élèves en gros oeuvre d'enrichir
leurs compétences et d'être plus armé
sur le marché du travail en 2010 80%
d'entre eux avaient trouvé un emploi
pour poursuivre leur formation avant de
se quitter on regarde ensemble l'agenda
pour tout connaître sur le télétravail
rendez vous à la cité des métiers
attrape un atelier sera organisé de 14 à
16 heures le 12 février pour les 45 ans
et plus qui rencontrent des difficultés
à retrouver un emploi
des conseils pourront leur être donnée
mercredi 13 ça se passe de 10 heures à
17 heures à la cité des métiers toujours
et enfin pour les plus jeunes un forum
de l'emploi sur les métiers du
développement durable est organisé du
mardi 19 au samedi 23 février
rendez vous à la maison de
l'environnement des sciences et du
développement durable à magny les
hameaux
c'est terminé pour ce fils échos merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
vendredi 22 février pour un nouveau
numéro